this film is a true story 1952 these men
won out in seven foot seas with zero
visibility no compass they saved 32
people on a boat that was only meant to
carry 12 people and they did this in the
span of like two and a half hours it's
such a life-affirming story there is the
big spectacle we shot in what was
actually an old shipyard and that's
where they used to build ships or in the
war and they built a pool it's about
half of a football field and they
reconstructed the ship and they had wind
machines and rain machines we were in a
water tank for half of the movie being
sprayed with fire hoses it all feels
very real as real as possible I'm a
completely immersive visual experience
and this is a movie that's all about
immersing yourself in something as
overwhelming as what it would be like to
be in a nor'easter over 70 foot waves
the scale of the waves and the scale of
the boat is pretty epic and not in 30
days is pretty special
this station chatham do you hear me